[Music]
there were some reports run that you
were meeting and talking wedding dress
it did so you talked to wedding dress I
did I really did so I've been convinced
you know I want pants
I want a very sexy pantsuit and Brian
honestly doesn't care but his mom does
my mom does and so I'm I'm getting into
the dress mode so I really went and
visited with Randy Rahm in New York sat
down with her talked about what I would
like to design of my dress to look like
and I think we have a nice compromise
with a dress and a pant oh you're
getting this is big Rachel because you
are really talking and designing a dress
with Randy Romney this is happening yeah
so does this mean a data set a date is
not set but we are getting I know how I
kind of want it to go and now I'm in a
place where is it going to be on TV if
it's on TV it'll look this way if it's
not on TV it'll look like this so I'm
getting in that mindset I really don't
want to play in a wedding so that's
that's also there so when people are
like do you have details I'm like baby
steps because I don't want to plan why
does this dress yeah just the stress
never thought that I would have this big
grand wedding so now I know it can
either go this way or this way
well we're getting closer so what will
determine this way or this way is it a
discussion with producers of whether
it's gonna be televised and then you'll
make the call what's happening yeah so
it's unfortunately it's not up to us if
we get the green light to do it you know
there's a lot of moving parts we fell in
love on TV we met on TV I feel like a
lot of people are invested in our love
story they want to see it come full
circle so I'm all about a TV wedding
it's just it's really about timing well
will the network give it to us will them
everything work together so these
discussions are happening with producers
to see if a TV wedding could happen sure
and when you say timing does that mean I
mean I know they've literally got like
schedules to fill but is it also in your
head I want to be married by x time X
year I yes okay
like we're older I like to call us the
og even though it was just last year
we're the older couple so when do you
want to be married by I
Springer 29 I mean I ideally I wanted it
a winter wedding I wanted it in December
but as it's getting closer
plants having been put in place it's
looking more next year so really the
spring because I want to have kids I
really want to start next year
I want more stability we've been
traveling so much I want to create this
family unit and a home for us
Wow so spring wedding and then you're
gonna move right into kids I think so I
love that I really do because we've been
having a great time we've been traveling
we live together so we've already done
the things that I thought oh I'll wait
two years once I get married we're
already doing that so it's like why wait
what's up kids
I also want to talk about a different
aspect of TV you have been on ESPN Lea I
love sports and I think people don't
realize that I majored in sports I went
to law school and focused in sports law
so I always knew I wanted to do ESPN but
I always thought I would be behind the
camera but then after doing the
bachelor/bachelorette the media circuit
I thought you know what I want to talk
about it when it's been something that
I've been working on for a year it
didn't happen overnight
and so to have that guest hosting spot
and to go from the couch watching it to
actually being in the seat it was an
amazing experience it was a dream come
true